whoa that was a long one that was a new
one
you've seen it I've seen it with my own
eyeballs
that streak of light you just saw is a
muon an elementary particle it came from
space and the only reason we can see it
is because of Einstein's relativity
[Music]
hey crazies we have over A Century of
evidence to back up Einstein's
relativity but the traditional
explanations aren't really relatable
nobody really experiences relativity in
their daily life so there's no basis for
comparison to see effects like time
dilation or length contraction really
fast speeds are required like speeds
close to that of light
Einstein often used trains in his
explanation because they were the
fastest form of travel at the time I use
rockets in my explanations for the same
reason unfortunately trains have gone
out of fashion and Rockets are a pretty
exclusive thing there just isn't
anything to connect with so these
explanations come across like trust me
bro so how do we fix this problem nuance
these muons actually come from space
muons from space
technically they don't actually come
from space space there are these things
called cosmic rays which come in and
collide with molecules in the atmosphere
and that Collision creates Nuance okay
so they're not from space they're from
the atmosphere right okay since most
atoms in the universe are hydrogen it's
almost always just a proton okay so a
cosmic ray is a proton moving at high
speed that's come from the Sun a cosmic
ray is really high energy it came from
some like distant Supernova or something
and it finally got here okay okay it
needs more energy than what the sun is
putting out yes the sun does send out
protons but they're not really like high
energy enough for this
there's kind of this like Collision
Cascade that generates particles which
then Decay into Auto particles which
then Decay into other particles
very common in
nature so you're familiar with that
familiar with the Cascade the big
particle that gets generated in this
Decay is muon okay which at first might
seem less relatable but you can actually
see them yourself like with an
experiment at home all you need is about
a hundred dollars worth of items you can
pick up at your local store a fish tank
a piece of felt some glue a couple
cooking trays some isopropyl alcohol the
higher the concentration the better I
use 99 a pair of thick protective gloves
these are leather about five pounds or
two kilograms of dry ice a decent
flashlight and a hammer some of these
items are pretty standard household
items so if you've got them around you
can save some money depending on where
you live the dry ice might be difficult
to find but I live in Rural America
where I can just pick it up at my local
supermarket
shout out to Meyer hashtag not a sponsor
right hashtag do you want to be a
sponsor hashtag please sponsor me
assembly is pretty straightforward first
glue the felt to the bottom of the tank
after the glue dries pour some of the
alcohol onto the felt not too much you
don't want it to be dripping wet just
wet but honestly it will work without
the felt if you want to skip it it just
won't work as well next while wearing
the gloves break the ice into pieces and
evenly spread it across one of the trays
dry ice exposure to the skin can be
dangerous so always wear the gloves
after you get the ice situated put the
second tray on top
yep
[Music]
okay
cover the top tray in a thin layer of
alcohol and place the fish tank upside
down on top
now we wait like five or ten minutes not
only is the dry ice sublimating into CO2
gas but the coal is also turning the
alcohol into a vapor you don't want to
be inhaling either of them make sure you
do this in a well ventilated area I
cracked the garage door I honestly
couldn't get this experiment to work
very well the first time for some reason
but I tried it again the next day and
got better results once we've waited
long enough turn off the overhead lights
and turn on a decent flashlight you
should see the alcohol Vapor whisping
about when you finally get it working
you'll see streaks of light zipping
through the vapor those are particles
[Music]
foreign and you can tell them apart by
the kinds of streaks they make for
example helium nuclei also known as
alpha particles or Alpha radiation are
really massive so we expect them to just
plow through the vapor in a straight
line they also take up a lot of space as
far as particles go so their streaks are
pretty beefy electrons are a lot less
massive so their trajectory is affected
more by the collisions they also take up
a lot less space than the helium so they
make shorter skinnier Jagged streaks
muons are like a combination of the two
they're more massive like helium nuclei
so their streaks should be longer and
straighter but they take up less space
like electrons so their streaks should
be skinny instead of beefy
whoa that was a long one that was a new
one you've seen it I seen it with my own
eyeballs I saw the particles it was very
exciting before you go on any further we
just want to give a quick shout out to
YouTube members no no YouTube YouTube
viewer number 2014. that's it YouTube
viewer yep number 2014 yep they are a
new channel member and they are pledging
at the Einsteinium level so they get a
shout out thanks so much for your
support and if anyone else would like to
help support us so that we can continue
making these videos please consider
signing up for patreon or the YouTube
membership now the thing about muons is
they're unstable also okay so they're
also not going to be around for very
long right if you like take all this and
average how long you expect of muon to
last it's somewhere around 2.2
microseconds that is a quite short we
know exactly how many of these muons we
would expect to finally make it down
here okay which is almost none right the
muons got their energy from that
original cosmic ray and so they're going
to be moving fast as well okay but if
they're only around for a few
microseconds there's only so far you can
go right at 2.2 microseconds we're
looking at about 660 meters or 0.4 miles
look at them go right and how far up is
the outer atmosphere 60 miles it's a
surprisingly long distance but
definitely not the thickness of the
atmosphere it's Fallen very short
however more of them Reach the surface
of the Earth than we expect like a lot
more a lot more like an order of
magnitude at least okay we need to be
able to explain that like how can
something that only lasts on average 2.2
microseconds make it to the Earth's
surface right right doesn't make any
sense and as it turns out
Einstein's relativity helps
one of the most well-known aspects of
Einstein's relativity is something we
call time dilation if some object like a
space station or a train or a particle
is moving relative to us then its time
is passing slower than it is for us that
difference becomes more dramatic the
closer its speed is to the speed of
light let's say this bad boy is
traveling at 99.99 the speed of light
according to relativity the muon's clock
is slower than ours by a factor of about
70. if the muon lasts for the average
2.2 microseconds that would look like
0.15 milliseconds to us that's enough
for the muon to travel over 28 miles
instead of the 0.4 miles I mentioned
earlier which granted is still only half
the atmosphere but that 2.2 microseconds
is only an average some of them last
longer maybe twice as long plus some of
them are going faster than 99.99 the
speed of light that means some of these
muons will reach the ground from our
point of view in fact it's exactly the
amount we'd expect after factoring in
Einstein's time dilation but hold up
what does that look like from the muon's
perspective
there's a pretty fundamental thing that
we consider in relativity and that is
that while a different Observer is
different particles or whatever can make
different observations of things like
time everyone must agree on which events
occur right yes so if from our
perspective the muons reach the ground
then from the muon's perspective they
must also reach the ground which is
interesting because so it must be a
shorter distance for them yes yeah and
so even though for them they're only
lasting on average 2.2 microseconds the
distance must be shorter right and it is
we have this thing called length
contraction as well right right the
entire Earth along with its atmosphere
has length contracted has compressed to
a distance that the muon can Traverse in
the time that it exists that's wild
that's like look at this little baby
Earth here right to have a way to
actually like see these muons in action
right and you actually me see them see
them with your eyeballs right not just
like you know the figurative use of the
word right we created a cloud chamber
that was about the size of a you know a
small average fish tank and in that
little fish tank within an hour we got
new ones yeah we got a couple of them
yeah if you actually try this it's a lot
like watching a meteor shower you think
there's going to be all these like you
know streaks across the sky but really
it's like one every once in a while but
they're exciting when you get one yeah
there's one very exciting and this is a
real life demonstration that we can
actually see in our garage you know
right with just stuff that we picked up
locally right less than a hundred
dollars right and we got to see these
muons that are living representations of
Einstein's relativity yeah which is wild
it's wild it's so cool it's very cool of
course this isn't a scientifically
rigorous experiment or anything in a
real experiment we would need to watch a
lot longer and record the proportions of
each particle and so on there's a
process this is more of a demonstration
you can actually see the particles
yourself but you're not collecting any
data the point is a higher proportion of
muons reached the Earth's surface than
our instincts would expect because of
Einstein's relativity from our point of
view the muons last longer than they
should because their clocks are slower
from the muon's perspective the distance
it has to travel is shorter because the
length contracts in either case the
result is the same the muon reaches the
ground relativity is real and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
quite a few of you commented that us
humans are making artificial rings with
our space junk there is a lot of junk up
there but not nearly enough to make a
planetary ring yet anyway thanks for
watching
foreign